no
d
today
and to
effort
for that
I usually
um
well
and
many
always charge that to
talk about this
in him
[Music]
yes
1 period
if you look
and gentlemen
before
and that's good
felix
well
the seventh the probable
I have
the animals every ten seconds
thanks for or what I was
[Music]
yes
s
and start
[Music]
projects
in the bags ourselves
and we go
yes
then my role is not essential it
is stipulated
yes
and we said
it's not your part
it's me
but  what he
feels right now
10 products
besides his name
and
the men so sublime spies that
walker 10
before
digital people
weaver
and visible
later he writes to us
[Music]
without exclusions
me in Spanish is one more practice but
this one describes more people
yes
it's little
[Music
] really
but no
and
the red ones
new that ministers and spray working
i
and that
choules
or not
and
easy
to caresses
well
let's go
the agglomerates that takes d  e promotion and
one of the exterior enzymes
no
and the things
on the ship are
me
with returning is this is more than we created
before
before you want
about
the colossus youtube the color of its
descents
let's see
[Music]
before they
look
at their passions
[Music]
we will be
for caesar
of the cities
[Music]
we
don't have yes
and without more they
have to have public
yes
ah
you feel
and
you wrote me although you
plant our interests
good
yes he
explained then we ended up
publishing the brooches grades
[Music
] asthma
[Music]
[Music  ]
m
one of the attractions
and yes
we see each other a topic that they call me
or
I have to know that
way I have 15
of themselves the facts
ah
in the suite
alone
but
not
and things
in images to
form new successes
the pixi
as
we say in great classics  he leans back
he gets worse
[Music]
before these images
that's right they
are means
and then characters
this person
to the national identity distances
[Music]
girls
and  fight of the probable future
the fans
more
and being
yes
more used
and
[Music]
but as much as it is done often
and a lot
yes yes it
is a minister
I am willing
or not
[Music]
then they have
the one of the commons you have to play
both coastal shoots
ah
in the way of educating
s you
don't like many hotels
as
giving up
that's positive
here they are
[Music]
and that's
not
like that
without nothing less
[Music]
are
you jealous
or not
and
so
and how
and so  everything starts
and for free then
we no longer look at each other
about that
and he
says
furcal and that he feels
yes of course
crisis he has written
[Music]
I am going to nominate I want to land in
front of
this message
news fight forums
I am properties to take my hands
for  mons
but the key
or
from his name
[Music]
of the same
yes
good morning
or
even it is in force
and sclerosis crowds
[Music]
james
ah
the bots
and things like that
to websites
in that month
search
yes
I
[Music]
o
yes
and development  the special thing
in the future
[Music]
we'll see
the natives
and
like that of the forensic doctor who is
not interested now
in 2005
reuters
this
says
or
then there would be a nation
like that
the distance back to
and
when identifying the number behind
I am
and yes
and  that link here
ah
[Music]
itself
but the exams
are like
this this name
no
ah in
front of her
yes
if you want
[Music]
gray
now
and
water
strong
nothing
that these plans
yes
that's wrong it
's the wall well
we're going to go to moscow  nation is where it
runs with migrations it
is like
that since that
is written
before
yes like
that
[Applause]
remember temperature inder wonder and it was
william hart of organs of effort
they Mexicans months of yours not of
temperature again factor are in
imagining my dressing room yours  espil de marc
puig des beaux arts
run out salt
me ​​consists of optimal
each calculator dimension of temperature
12 of increase
and station
and
strength
care
morton is the festivity
why
and m  much
with this control it
does not go
to questions about
the modules
also
here he
believes that not
for
them which you have on
the air
is this or whatever it is
like this it is
to you
in this way for the 20% passion for the
stings
the
james jones company
if you walk
their faults
just cares
[Music]
I wanted
more
[Applause]